We brought together seven people who are parents. I'm a parent, I'm a parent,
I'm a parent. I'm.
A parent. I'm a parent. I am a parent and I.
Am the parent. One of them is a liar.
If the group discovers who the liar is, the survivors win a cash prize.
If the liar survives, they win the prize.
Can the group find the odd man out right now?
My strategy for this game is I actually wrote down some very specific questions.
All I know is I'm not trying to get voted out the first round. So.
I'm looking to bond with these other parents.
I think I'm a really good judge of, uh, who's a parent and who's not.
I have no game plan going into this. I'm going to do my best.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
All right. We're about to start. Oh,
and the time starts now.
Oh, wow. I don't know what you're supposed to do in these first three minutes.
It's it's pretty crazy. Well, hi everyone.
I am a dad. This is like rapid fire,
45.
I'm 43 and chaotic.
I guess this video is kind of gonna be my, uh, I have a two years old daughter,
my reveal.
Okay. Okay. I'm 29 and a death.
24 mom.
I remember his first poop.
I'm the worst typer. They're going to think.
I'm the oldest because I suck at tubing. Oh my goodness. Everyone.
37. I'm expecting sending this number. Oh.
Just started. You get used to lots.
My friends. Oh, no clip. You haven't told anybody. Oh no.
Which is true. Like, and he sits still for it for the very first time,
which is incredible. Uh, before he would just skip all these videos, videos,
videos, videos, videos, and it was driving me insane.
Uh.
I feel like so much of this is just trying to prove that your not the one
as opposed to sniffing someone out. Um, but I don't know
how old is everyone's kid.
My oldest boy is three.
No idea. I have no idea.
Uh, parents,
uh, say my house is like a kindergarten.
I don't know Johnny. That seems sus sus
Holy crap. This is going so fast.
Crystal's favorite toy story character, I guess does that matter?
I feel like I should have a notepad
who is single. I'll keep watching, but they're single.
I just feel good. I feel good about that round.
I felt great about the round. I'm a little suspicious.
I'm not really sure who to vote for. I kinda want to vote for Dyneesha.
Like her responses were very short.
I think I'm going to have to go with Dyneesha. I'm so sorry.
Daneesha actually said that I'm definitely a parent.
I think everyone saw that crystal. I'm so sorry,
but I'm probably going to vote for you for this round because you say my
favorite character of toy story is Boulpaep
probably Johnny. I can tell you all about being a parent.
Same what?
I'm going to vote for Johnny this round? Uh, mostly because Johnny said,
I can tell you anything about being a parent. And like,
I don't know that Blaine's statement and cockiness.
I'm going to vote for crystal.
And that's probably what that's probably what single people are doing.
Non-parents is they're thinking about themselves and not the kid to
Nisha Janisa just has my vote for this one
is the mole.
She spaced her kids out really far.
I have no idea who I'm voting for it and it's around. I know it's not Johnny or,
uh, I think Daniel's, we'll see what happens.
I tally the votes and it came out to three way
tie. What the hell? That's insane.
The three way tie was between the Nisha. Johnny
[inaudible] you too is every
study. We'll vote again.
Voting.
Why was I voted out?
I don't know.
I have a gut feeling about Johnny and I think need to stick with my vote.
I got to stick with my gut and go crystal because people
that are parents instinctively say what their kid likes, not what they like.
I think,
I think it's crystal because I go with my gut.
The person who was eliminated in our first round is crystal.
Sorry. I should've said that. My daughter liked Vokey.
Not that I liked Bo peep though. It's true. I do. She's great
for this round.
Tell a brief story about you and your child and the time they overwhelmed you.
It was probably nearing the end of my second pregnancy when I was like nine
months he's he was two at the time and he
decided that he wanted to clog our toilet.
So he just pooped in the toilet,
stuck the whole bunch of toilet paper in the thing flooded that
I walk out he's covered in water. I feel like that's really gross.
Um, my kid just gets hyped.
All of a sudden he's three puts his hands on the wall and starts twerking.
And then the one-year-old copies what my kid is doing. I was like,
where did you learn that from?
And my wife and I always pointing fingers at each other. That's definitely you.
Okay. Hi everyone. So real quick. My, when my daughter was four,
she had a very loud voice.
So every single night she screamed so loud for hours that she doesn't want to go
to sleep. And we even tried to put in ear buds and we're like, hold on a second.
Let me try this. There's no difference. She's so loud that we can never.
Whenever I do my makeup, I let my daughter use like a lip gloss.
Because one time she took one of the expensive lipsticks that I have and she
called her whole face with it, her whole face. And it was a matte lipstick,
but it was so hard to get.
That was teaching my son how to snowboard.
And we ski down into the line and he
shouts out with no reason to no rhyme. Daddy,
I'm going to marry a man and everybody in the crowd heard it and
looks at me and I'm like, good for you, bud.
Whoever you want to marry is who you want to marry. That's my story.
Um, gosh, I can't think of a story.
I guess I'll tell you about the story with my 19 year old. Um,
a few months ago he got frustrated with me and he tried to commit suicide
right in front of me. Um,
it was really scary and we couldn't call. I was at work.
We couldn't call nine one one.
Cause it was during the time where we thought maybe a cop would shoot him if
they went to my house and I didn't know what to do. So,
um, it was probably the worst day or worst time of my life.
I w I was really scared. And I don't know if any parents got,
have, have experienced this, but it's the worst feeling you could ever feel it,
even throwing it now makes me want to cry.
Thank you for sharing.
It looks nice. Getting to see everybody. No idea after that round.
When everybody else was talking about that, it was funny and cute.
But when it came to my party, it was just right.
Dinetia story. Oh my goodness.
That was one of the most harrowing things I've heard in a really long time.
I think I'm going to go Johnny,
just because there was some heat on Johnny from the last, from the last boat,
I would probably vote for Daniel just because of the lack of details and the
lack of description. I might just stick with my gut.
Sorry.
Johnny seemed like he was telling more of a generic story.
I'm gonna have to go with Johnny.
I really feel like you should be the one to raise your kid instead of hiring
people to raise your kid. I'm going to put Johnny again. I pick up your girl,
like the second person eliminated from the game
is Johnny. Oh, I'm sorry, John.
Ah, I guess I really don't look like a parent.
I should have addressed in like a polo shirt that
sucks.
You will have four minutes to talk to each other.
And the time starts now, who is the one who said, um,
I don't know what to do with a three plus year old. You've got to me. Okay.
So my oldest is a three year old from, um, in July, July six. And,
uh, she just loves a lot of Marvel,
like on Disney plus there's like a whole bunch of Marvel stuff that you can
watch. Um, I don't know who was the one no screen time. Was that Johnny?
That'd be, we already voted him off, right? Yeah. Um,
how old are you? I'm 20.
I had my first, um, I was 20 and I turned 21 when I had him.
Wow.
How you do it as a young cause I was 36, seven,
eight when it all happened and it just, it's a very different ceiling, dude.
I don't know how you guys do. I feel like I'm tired all the time. Like
I think it's just because like, since we're young, we have a lot of energy.
What time to your kids go to bed? Like,
do you guys have a bedtime for your kids? Routine seven.
O'clock in the bath seven and my wife starts at eight.
What's the oldest out of all you guys. Cause I think I have the oldest.
I think you did the oldest 19.
We voted, voted the Mola. I sort of hear more from you being
in daycare or have any of you guys had your kids in daycare? Yeah,
but my kids in daycare, my wife's a physician and I work full time.
So like if he wasn't in daycare, he would take all my energy,
like all, every second of myself just to entertain him.
So there's no way we can do both.
And we're just like so grateful that our daycare is staying open with a small
amount of kids. And like every parent is just trying to be careful.
I used to work at a daycare, but now I'm a stay at home mom.
So like since I've had, not that there's anything wrong with daycares,
but since I've been there, it's like, I kinda know like what goes on.
I just rather would spend time with her at home because daycare is expensive.
I'm just struggling with what we're going to do with this distant learning or
hybrid learning. But that that's one that one's terrible. Yeah.
Yeah. Our school districts have already emailed us that we're,
we're doing it now.
Clarity. I was just doing a hybrid, uh, at a certain point,
starting off with just some learning,
but then they're going to go into a hybrid if we left.
Everybody's really good. Everybody's convincing. They've got their story down.
I am the youngest. I'm the youngest. I'm the youngest one on here.
So hopefully they all have that mentality. Like yo,
she's not the mole.
I think it was Daniel Dre and Emily that I was kinda concerned about.
But cliff seems like he's definitely a parent Daniel. Gosh,
it's almost Daniel and Emily because Emily was talking too much.
I think I am going to go with Daniel.
I wanted more out of him.
And I wonder if he is just a sophisticated
man that knows the ropes of parents.
Does that make sense? I feel like cliff was right when he said that we,
we thought the mole without police wanted to talk,
but if I had to choose someone, it'd probably
be Emily. I don't know who I'm going to go with.
I might go with Daniel and I go, cliff, I'm going to go with
the results of the last round was we had another tie.
The tie is between Daniel and Emily.
So what we're going to actually do for this round is we're going to have
each person gets 30 seconds to state their case. Daniel, you go first.
All right, did to get this right.
You shouldn't believe me because I have the adoption certificate to prove it.
I have the divorce financial bills to prove that I fought
for custody. Um,
because I have the smartest little monkey trying to make his little Minecraft
world on his YouTube channel. And it's a delight.
Uh, I have all of the poop stories. We try to do, uh,
elimination communication early on. Who's actually potty trained by nine, which.
Worked until one year. And then it went all to waste. Um,
unintended jokes galore. I'm definitely.
All right. And your time starts now.
Okay. Also Daniel said that he got probate.
Does it got proof to show that right now? But I do. I'm 22, the Matthew on 20.
My daughter's two. Right? And I have this tattoo right here. 10,
1970s. It's her birthday. It's her birthday.
Why would I have just have this random tattoo?
Do the math is her birthday 22.
That's the best proof I could show y'all right now. That's all my body. Um,
I love you. You're so sweet.
She's using a tattoo to prove her case,
but I feel like that could have been like a boyfriend, a girlfriend, you know,
no girl, I'm sorry.
What do we do here? What do I do think it was a good guy.
Nice person.
Very close, low.
But the next person eliminated is Emily
guys.
So I just got eliminated and I had a feeling I wasn't going to make it to the
last round. If you really think about it. When you think of parents,
I feel like people wouldn't put me in that category unless you see my child's,
um, standing next to me.
And even then my daughter doesn't really look like me cause she's mixed.
So even then people would still think that I am not a parent.
If the majority decides they've already popped mall,
they can go ahead and end the game.
But if the majority feels they haven't caught them all and they want to keep
going, they can continue the game.
Oh, I thought this was going to be a lot easier.
Why would they want to continue? We should end the game. I really think that
Emily was a parent.
So
Neisha and Dre said and the game and desert
continue. If the image I show you is a green,
you've caught the mall and you won. And if the image is red,
the mole is still in the game and you've lost
because I voted to keep going. All right, here we go.
Three, two, one.
[inaudible] I'm going to have them all reveal themselves.
When I count down to one,
the mole can raise their hand and reveal it him or herself. Three, two,
one, go ahead and raise.
Here's what's funny. This is the first time I'm seeing crystal really?
Oh yeah, because if it's from the chat, right,
I'm a horrible typer and I just couldn't keep up.
It's like I had answers to everything.
I have a lovely three and a half year old niece. I just,
I just can't type.
It's really easy to talk to other parents. It really is.
Especially when you're in a room together and you have to, it was just nice.
Seeing other people from a different perspective. I was a lot of fun.
It was fun to me,
to people and have a fun little game and diversion in this crazy COVID times.
I think the important reminder we always should have is to not judge a book by
its cover.
I definitely wish that I could have learned more from the
parents on here because one day maybe I will be a parent in some
capacity.
And I would've loved to have heard their honest experiences.
Time is so valuable.
So spend it as best as you can with the kids that you have around you.
Everyone can be a parent, but be a good one. Don't raise. No,
we don't need any more of those. What defines a good parents?
I think it's definitely. Oh my goodness. This is the struggle of a parent.
They never leave. All right. Well there's nothing else to add.
This has been a fun and great experience. Say bye-bye.
Okay.